I'm going to be starting a new series of
videos for the side Trek Channel The
Good the Bad and the stupid and first of
all we're going to be doing sci-fi hand
weapons
so let's get into it
[Music]
before we get into it I've got two
honorable mentions two hand weapons that
I adore but that I couldn't quite get
onto this list the particle Magnum Ronan
dex's weapon in Stargate Atlantis I just
love that gun I prefer this
I can see where you would
and I'm blue holes that like this size
in people and it was just a brilliant
weapon I love the character and I just
love that gun but it didn't quite make
the list the other one is the dl-44
heavy Blaster from Star Wars the weapon
was Han Solo's Choice it was just a
great design I adored it I wanted one
when I was a kid but again it doesn't
quite make the cut so first of all we've
got the good the hand weapon that I just
love because I think it makes sense I
thought it was designed well it was
brilliantly used in the series and to be
honest it just looked cool
the zat nickatel
or just the zat as O'Neill used to call
it because he you know couldn't be
bothered to pronounce that this
discipline that fired a kind of
electrical charge it was basically a
very powerful stun gun now it was kind
of like an electrical energy and that it
hit metal or can anything conductive it
would then travel along that surface I
love the sound it used to make I Love
Actually the way they used to pop up it
was like a safety mechanism even though
once or twice it was fired without it
popping up continuity here oops
I kind of really like the way that you
shoot once just done and of course pain
you shoot twice that would kill most
people not always and then a third time
would you know disintegrate to the
person even though we didn't get to see
that very often I like the way that they
even thought about how the energy would
kind of dissipate so you could be shot
once and stun you and if you waited a
bit you could be shot once again and it
would just stun you again
I think this is a weapon that was really
thought through it was a weapon that was
powered by an aqueduct again something
the gold liked it was a weapon that I
could see the goal world would create
and it is actually a very very useful
sidearm the ability to be able to stun
kill or disintegrate your prey is a very
useful one for storytelling the writers
of geniuses this by the way they came up
with this a weapon that really allowed
so many different possibilities within
the story arcs that you know you can't
really do with a handgun
um so they were Geniuses but actually if
the weapon was real again it would be
insanely useful I refuse to carry as
that I will say this because they
actually put it as a sidearm for us at
certain points
um and I refused to because I thought it
was the dumbest weapon ever invented by
sci-fi
first of all and you have to understand
this you only see it when it's like you
know shooting out of CGI rays and stuff
like that if you see it in reality as
you see some of the people walking
around with the replicas it's a penis
so the good it is that nicotel the Bob
the law Giver Mark II from Judge Dredd
now before you can hand grab me it's a
very cool gun the way it works is very
cool the way it looks is very cool
but the way it would actually work in
reality is just unfathomable now the
mark one lawgiver made loads of sense it
actually had like three or four
different magazines which held the
different types of ammunition because if
you don't know the law Giver actually
fired like six different types of
ammunition I have a list
[Music]
it has the standard execution which is
just basically a bullet it has armor
pieces it has a Ricochet round which is
like a titanium rubber
um incendry round Hot Shot which is a
heat seeking round and and it had gas
around and had the option of grenades
but that was like you put in a different
magazine in grenade and fire grenades
unless the magazine that went into this
weapon was designed by time Lords as in
like it was a tardis basically and it's
bigger on the inside than it is on the
outside then the Mark II is just stupid
it's just a bad design you couldn't get
loads of different types of ammunition
into the dam magazine and even if you
could what if the incending rounds at
the bottom what's inside that magazine
is it just like a little elevator system
they go oh you want that one we're gonna
wake up to the top it's just a rubbish
design for a handgun it doesn't make any
logical sense and even though it was
used beautifully the reason why it's in
the bad for me is because there was a
logical mark one that made sense and
then they replaced it with a Mark II
because it looked better and that's
basically the only reason it looked
better so no for me it 100 goes in the
bad
mainly compared to the Mach 1 which
actually made sense
the stupid
the Star Trek phaser is probably my
favorite handheld weapon of any Sci-Fi
series
I loved it I love the sound it makes I
loved in the Next Generation how it was
very different to the original you know
with a grip and everything and even
though I loved the original version of
the phaser I thought it actually fit
with the feel of the show and it just
became iconic but the TNG phaser again
you could go from stun to kale to
vaporize if you wanted to I love how
they have the little Mark type one phase
it was just tiny little thing that could
flip into your back pocket sort of thing
I just thought the phases have always
been absolutely brilliant and even like
the new ones where they're now more of
like a bolt shot rather than that stream
that we got in TNG so why am I
mentioning it for the stupid category
because JJ Abrams got hold of a phaser
and he did that stupid flippy thing
where it was red once I blew the other
is stun or kill and you could physically
see it by which way it was facing I mean
how stupid a star Fleet basically that
they need a visual representation of
which way the barrel is pointing to tell
whether the gun is set to stun or kill
oh
[Music]
I mean okay
the filmmakers did that because they
wanted to do a toy and the toy
manufacturers told them we need
something that moves
we pull the trigger and it sort of like
spins around and it'll be cool the kids
will love it
that's why they did it but in reality it
was just a ridiculous design
now we they lost it a little bit later
on in the movies fair enough but in the
first film in particular I believe the
second film it was prominent I mean we
saw it in loads in the first film and
every time it was flipping around and
going for the oh man I just wanted to go
what the now I like the JJ Abrams
movies their action movies they're fun
they're quite well made and I love a
lens flare I'm being a bit sarcastic
there but you know it's full of them but
I like most of the films I just don't
think I'm the Star Trek they're not
track I just pretend it's just a film
with some similar representations of a
show I like
and that way it doesn't make me too
angry
but things like what they did to the
Enterprise make a bit enormous and what
they did to the phases does annoy me
it is just ridiculous it's stupid
there's no reason for it technically or
any other thing I mean for me it just
creates one thing to break on the damn
thing I want to get stuck it gets stuck
off around what happens then so shooting
both ways it's just idiotic and that's
my main problem that good it's idiotic
so yeah the good does that nicotyle the
Bad Judge Dread Mark II law giver and
they're just stupid JJ Abrams Facebook
but guys get to the comments and tell me
what you think what sci-fi weapons
haven't I mentioned that you love I'm
thinking like robocops handgun and
things like that get into the comments
and tell me I have to admit one hand gun
whatever you want to call it that really
did nearly make this list was the noisy
cricket from Men In Black
that weapon was just idiotic from
beginning to end but it was a film that
was supposed to be a comedy so it was
supposed to be idiotic so I couldn't
really put it in the list but would you
have get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and for a
small charge each month that you can
really support the Channel with you get
to see them without the adverts you even
get a free gift after three months
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
foreign
[Music]